Hello I'm Jonathan Worth and as well as being a freelance photographer I'm also
a Senior Researcher at Newcastle University's Open Lab in the UK.
The interviews you're about to hear are a part of a series that along with the web
platform and connected classes seeks to create a space for critical engagement
with visual storytelling. The audio montage is of several separate
interviews, including a photographer their subject and someone who represents
the audience. The photographer is Isadora
Kosofsky and her two subjects are
Vincent and Felicia. The audience perspective is provided by Peter DiCampo.
Isadora is a Los Angeles-based photographer, she was also a 2014
World Press Photo Joop Swart Masterclass participant. She's received distinctions
for her work from Women and Photography International, Prix de la Photographie, Paris
and the New York Film Festival. Vincent and Felicia are subjects from
Isadora's project Vinnie and David 'Life and incarceration of a family'.
Peter is one of the cofounders of the Instagram project Everyday Africa,
a project that led him to think deeply on how different audiences interpret images.
Pete Brooke is our subject specialist and he gives a contextual overview.
Many will know Pete from his days writing for Wired, others will know him from his
prison photography project and its collation of the many different forms of
image making the related to mass incarceration. The starting point in
these interviews was thinking about who we as photographers are talking to,
sort of who are intended audiences are and how different audiences might interpret our work.
You'll hear Isadora describes her approach to storytelling, how she
searches out her subjects and when she
finds them how she builds and commits to
long-term relationships with them. You're also going to hear about how the process
of doing the interviews for this course have affected Isadora, how they've made
her reflect on the impact she's had on her subjects. And as we listen, it is worth
considering how our own approaches to storytelling affect the story itself.
We're going to find that context is a recurring theme in this talk and in
different guises as we listen to Felicia describes her incomprehension and why
anyone would want to see photographs of their lowest moments. We might turn that
into a question for ourselves: 'What are the moments where we've considered
photographs unnecessary or inappropriate? Are there moments in life where
photography is entirely obsolete and how might that value question change with
context? What are the contextual ingredients
required for the mundane to become interesting or of consequence? As in the
case here where Felicia's darkest moments might have a deeper and wider social
resonance. Don't forget to use the platform to share your notes and to make
comments on other people's. Listen to the audio in your own time taking time to
pause reflect and interrogate any hot sections in the transcript. Make the most
of the connected classes and build your
network of peers. Isadora:
My name is Isadora Kosofsky, I'm a documentary photographer and I'm
speaking to you from my studio apartment in Los Angeles, California.
Vinnie and David 'Life and incarceration of a family', a 5-year documentary photo essay that
I'm continuing to work on, begins with Vinnie who was 13 when the project began when
he was incarcerated for stabbing his mother's assailant and shadows him and
his older brother David then aged 19. The long-term photo essay focuses on the
brothers' lives in their family, community and respective incarcerations over five years
in Albuquerque, New Mexico. (Vinnie) My name is Vincent, I'm with the project of Vinnie
and David. The first time I met Dora I was in recreational time in the youth
detention center and I realized that she was taking photographs of other inmates
that were with me, she asked me if I would like to have an interview with her
and I responded with the answer yes. (Isadora) I was intrigued, I don't think that it was
entirely his appearance, there was something striking about how small he
was in stature, he was also striking that he was so confident, he evoked a depth
and maturity. I followed him into the unit
and he sat down in front of the television screen and he chose to sit
across from a number of boys who were sitting on the other side of the room,
he sat by himself in an empty row of chairs and I approached him, I sat down next to
him and I asked him what are you doing
here?
(Vinnie) My mom started getting beat up by a male and I, I defended my mother and the right
way I was taught and the right way I knew, I wasn't trying to hurt nobody but
unfortunately I had no choice to, so, I got in trouble for defending my mom.
(Isadora) He had been arrested for stabbing the man who was assaulting his mother, who he had
already witnessed for many years being abused by men, he said that he couldn't
take seeing his mother get hurt anymore.
Vinnie began telling me about his
relationship with his brother and of course speaking of the love for his
mother and his concern for her. (Vinnie) I really didn't know what to think about the
camera, when you started taking pictures it was kind of like hmm do I smile or do
I not smile? It was one of those. The main thing was, you paid attention.
You respected everything I said and you
listened, you didn't try to interrupt me,
and that matters. (Isadora) Had you ever spoken with a journalist before? (Vinnie) Not once in my life.
(Pete Brook) The United States is addicted to incarceration, only recently has the
country begun to admit as much. (Jonathan) Prison Photography blog founder Pete Brooke:
First, some facts: every year two million youth are arrested in the United States.
On any given night there are at least 60,000 children behind bars.
Some estimates have it as high as 65,000. With an average cost of $80,000 per year to
lock up a child, the US spends more than five billion dollars annually on
youth detention. In more wealthy states such as California, it can cost up to two
hundred thousand dollars per year to incarcerate a single child.
By contrast, spending in the California public school system ranges from seven
thousand to eighteen thousand per student per year. Why did the US juvenile
prison system grow so much? Well, throughout the 1980s and 1990s juvenile
detention began to mimic the adult system. Juvenile systems built facilities
that functioned like adult prisons, incapacitation became the mantra and in
such a political climate, rehabilitation for youth was sidelined or suspended
altogether. During an uptick in violent crime in the 80s and 90s there emerged a
hysteria about young criminals, there are brandish super-predators feral
teenagers of terrorized society. (Isadora) I saw Vinny and I knew that he was gonna
be the subject of a long term project, but I was struck by what he was saying
about his brother and how his brother wasn't good but he wasn't bad and he was
somebody that he loved and admired. He spoke of his brother as a kind of father
figure and I wanted to know this brother just from hearing about him. I don't think
that you can shoot for an audience particularly when working on a long term
series, you have to shoot for the subject and you have to shoot in relation to the
curiosity that you have about that subject, because at the end of the day,
the person most impacted is gonna be the subject.
When I met Vinny I knew that he was somebody that I wanted to know, I wanted to know
about him, I wanted to know about his mother, I wanted to know about his
brother. It was a curiosity, it was a connection that I felt burning inside of
me that I had to pursue. I had been looking for a family that bared the
dynamics that I was trying to tell in the juvenile detention facility but I
couldn't tell their story within the confines of a carceral setting because
that's setting in and of itself defines the subject. You're not able visually to
see the subject anywhere else but in that facility if you're only shooting
there and to me that was limiting. Of course the images of time spent in there
are fundamental to the story but they're not the entirety of the story. Had I just
photographed Vinnie, I would have simplified the story, I would have
reduced the story. The fact that the body of work contains multiple narratives
allows for multiple conversations from an audience. People are able to relate to
the experience of being a brother, a sister a mother and that is what my
intention has been from the beginning. I think that people need to see this
family as family first, as brothers first and as incarcerated people second.
Can you describe the first time that you saw the photograph that I took of you?
(Vinnie) The first time I had actually seen
a photograph of me was in the visitation room with my mother, we were both crying.
I couldn't go home with my mother and, and in the experience of that visit
that was my first visit with my mom, I really felt that I let my mom down
even though she felt she let me down because I couldn't go back to have that
peace of mind and my mom that I was there to protect her.  (Isadora) What was it like to have like a document of that moment?
It gives me something to look back on the moment of the photo makes me think
that from where I was to where I am now I've learned from that. (Peter DiCampo) I mean I think
the responsibility that she feels to the to the subjects in this case is directly
tied in to the idea of long form journalism. (Jonathan) Everyday Africa co-founder
Peter DiCampo: of sort of responding to or rather protecting their, not
protecting but respecting their
vulnerability, respecting the power that
she has in this situation. Some interesting sort of comparison to
Everyday Africa, I mean because you know we're, we're we're not dealing with a
with a family structure, we're not dealing with any one sort of subject
matter, you know, we're we're trying to broaden their perspective, isn't of an
entire continent and in that way it is its own form of a long term story. I was
really struck by her saying that you don't shoot a long-term project for an
audience, you do it you know thinking thinking only of the subject and and of
course I completely understand what she's saying you know, she's, her
predominant concern is whether she is treating her subject fairly, whether
she's showing them in a way that is fair
and positive to them. But it's
interesting to me because to me her work is so much about what it can teach to an
audience, what, what we can learn from it, you know the degree to which humanizing
these characters helps us understand more about the system of incarceration
as a broader issue. And so presumably perhaps those choices come up in the
editing process, once she sort of is able to, you know, have the headspace to say
okay now I'm just thinking about how I'm going to present this work and then of
course she's choosing the images that, that move the narrative
along but also the images that give us sort of a lot of the most intimate
moments, at times the most sort of everyday life moments again all of those
things that help us humanize the characters, that help us, you know,
identify with them and help us learn who they are and so from that
perspective it seems to be very much
about what can, you know, what can the
photographer deliver to the audience, what can the photographer teach the audience.
So much of what she's trying to accomplish here is a degree of context,
a degree of the why basically, you know why do these things happen, why this
particular boy, the social factors that lead up to this, the family factors that
lead up to this, you know if you, if you showed incarceration purely as, as people
in prison I mean that's not a, I mean that shows what life and prisoners like
or in this case life in a youth facility but, but it doesn't show, it doesn't
answer any of our questions of how did we get to this point in a way that long
form and, and more in-depth journalism of any genre or any medium can accomplish.
And so you know to me it's, it's once you sort of start to think about her
motivations and hear from her why she did the body of work and of course she
moved out of what she calls the carceral setting because you have to get into the
family life. It draws us into who they are as characters in addition to
providing us some of the answers for, you know, what does this all mean, I mean what
her work accomplishes is, it's sort of breaking down that barrier of just
assuming people in any kind of Correctional Facility must have sort of
done something to to get there, right, done something to deserve it and of
course once you get into their family life and, and you know the broader
situation and once you kind of see them become sort of humanized by, you know,
through following her photo essay, it just teaches you that there's so much
more to the situation.
(Isadora) When I sat down in Albuquerque New Mexico with Vinny when he was 18 in
order to conduct an interview of him about his experience of being the
subject of my long-term project, I was able to hear his experience of the
project which I have not heard before. I didn't know that they cried when they
saw the article, the first article through time. I didn't know that they
cried when they would look at the photos that I sent and that has changed the way
that I look at my subjects because I feel seen, I feel seen now that I know
that the photos and the process have impacted them. (Felicia) My first impression of you
honestly was, I thought wow people just aren't that amazing and nice and
generous and sweet and just beautiful. When you said it or when I asked why are
you always taking pictures she said that's what I do I'm a photographer and I
really fell in love. I am with you, there
was something I always wanted to do and
have a career in because taking pictures was always so like meaningful to me and
I got to see you do it and you got to do it for a living and travel and just
enjoy it. That first day I met you, you took us from the motel to McDonald's to
buy the kids food and we got out at McDonald's you started taking pictures
and I just thought,
what does she care about us for like what is this what is her real intention?
Like and at the same time I was just like man I wish I could do that. (Isadora) What was the experience like of first being photographed and how did it make you feel?
(Felicia) Just became kind of natural, have you take pictures of us, I mean even at some of
the worst of the worst baddest times like it was just natural that we'd let
you take pictures of us and be there and be a part of the family. (Isadora) Can you describe David's responses when he first saw the photos?
(Felicia) He cried. First time he ever saw any of the pictures you took of us and they were the ones of him
and Lily in the park, him walking down the street from my mom's house pushing
Lily in the stroller. Ones of me and him
and his mom's crying together in the
street, pictures of me at the park being
pregnant with Lily.
He cried, we both cried. (Isadora) What was it like for the family to see the article in TIME?
(Felicia) Every single one of anybody in the family that saw it when they saw it
cried. I mean they were all, you know, loved it and joyful and happy about it
but in the beginning the first time that any of us saw it we cried, all of us,
the images that you capture and the way you told their story like through pictures
was just amazing, like like who does that? This girl, it was it was truly amazing
and it deeply touched everybody especially for everybody in the family.
It's just so meaningful and sad but yet it brings so much joy at the same time
to know that somebody puts so much effort in to tell their story when it
was like we were the lowest of the low like who wants to even be around us, see us,
let alone care about what we're going through or photographing us at the
lowest of the low like and that that's that's deeper there.
(Isadora) I don't, I don't particularly want to
feel seen because it's vulnerable but I
know as a photographer that you have to be vulnerable with your subjects in
order for them to be vulnerable with you. Not only do they see themselves in the
photos, they also see me and I very much overlook the fact that I am even a
person sometimes when I'm shooting
because I have to be a kind of welcoming
wall, because I have to withstand painful moments and I cannot react, I cannot act
in moments that perhaps other people could because I'm in a capacity of being
witness, of bearing witness and of using the photographs to create larger change
than I would be able to in a moment of reaction in that space with that family.
This family sees me that I am someone in their lives and people listening this
may seem odd but in the process that I go through as a photojournalist I try
and overlook that I feel that I am invisible and when I showed the photos
to Vinnie in 2014 before it went live on time.com, I asked him if the photo essay,
the edit, not the photos in general, the edit that was going to be published was
true to his experience and he said yes and that's when I knew it was ready to
be shown. He said 99% and I said what would give
me that 1% authenticity or truthfulness? He said, well, you could never know what I
feel like, so I can't give you a hundred percent, I can only give you 99%. I don't
feel that I need Vinnie, David or Felicia and I don't feel that
they need me whatsoever. It's a healthy dynamic, it is a complex
dynamic between my subjects and I, between that family and my identity as a
photographer. I don't need them and they don't need me but I want them and they
want me which is, I believe, a normal response to a long-term relationship.
I know that Vinnie mentioned that he feels that I've somewhat inspired him to have
a healthy life, I don't know if that's entirely true, David said to me, I've
never really liked pictures, pictures don't lie, a photo is evidence.
That's something that has stuck with me as I've worked with that family, that I needed
to make photos into catalysts for compassion because visual media had been
used and is used as a way to incarcerate people, photography is used as a weapon
against families like Vinnie and David's family. Do you think that people
empathize with you through this photos?
(Vinnie) As a matter of fact, the sympathy I have had for some of the
photos I got, for example, I got pulled over and a cop ran my name and he
and came back to my vehicle he goes: you're on the internet for defending
your mom and I didn't know that that was what that was for
and I said yeah, he goes well good job and that brought me confidence. I knew at
that point that there, it was no greater than it could get.
(Jonathan) One of the participants commented that these conversations between the subject and
photographer may be more humanizing than photographs alone.
How does listening to Vincent and Felicia affect your reading of the work?
Do you think the images are an accurate reflection of the relationships you've
heard described? Isadora talks about overlooking her own impact. In the full
interview she talks of being a part of the fabric of the moment and that's
probably a convenient oversight that most, perhaps all, photographers make to
some degree. Isadora says that she shoots for her subjects and her, that her
subjects become her friends or by her commitment to the relationship her
friends become her subjects. She says she doesn't shoot for an audience or more
accurately that she isn't cognizant of the audience when she's shooting.
We shouldn't take away from that, that she isn't mindful of them, I mean, she's not
saying that she's photographing in a creative vacuum because she's not.
If anything she's hyper aware of the audience, she might not be shooting for
an audience but she's certainly editing a vision of the world for one.
Isadora says that she couldn't limit her images of Vinnie to a castle setting,
that the setting would define the subject and she introduces us to the
notion of transcarceral and says that she needed to photograph the mother and
the brother in order to make photographs that act as catalysts for empathy,
bridges between the subject and the audience. We put in mind of advice that
the photographer Lisette Model purportedly gave to a young Diane Arbus.
She said that the more specific you are, the more general you'll be. In other
words if you want to talk about aging then photograph your grandparents
because everyone can relate personally to the notion of a grandparent figure.
And each of us will have relatable ties, as Isadora calls them,
with the idea of a mother, a brother, a girlfriend a boyfriend, just as we will a
warm embrace or a tearful hug, and once on the inside of that emotion once drawn
in she leads us further into the catastrophic loneliness that must come
to an isolated incarcerated thirteen-year-old child.
There is also a wake-up call in there for us as audience, our impact.
Isadora says that she didn't know the family cried when they saw the pictures,  that's
a moment we, us an audience, and the subject shared, they saw their lives
recontextualized as or photographic equivalent of an out-of-body experience,
looking on the story of that time in
their lives but through a third set of
eyes. But also for the first time
experiencing those moments without
Isadora in front of them, without the photographer present. Think about that:
Your subject with whom you've built a trust relationship and who's allowed you
to make their picture, will be alone in front of an audience come publication.
And on one level, your picture will be a portrait of your relationship with them.
Isadora says again in the extended interview that she feels the social
resonance of the work comes with the personal connection she forms with those
subjects and as photographers ourselves of differing ages and backgrounds,
it will be interesting to know if you think that Isadora's age, relative to her
subjects, her gender, her race, if all those things affect this story,
I'm asking how important is Isadora? Isadora talks about how her approach to
photography negates abandonment and both Vinny and Felicia refer to the fact that
she returned, that she did what she said she'd do and how important that was for them.
And then Isadora builds on that by reflecting on how documentary
photography's relatable ties lessen loneliness for her personally and the
subject and the audience too. Perhaps that's that's a part of the currency of
this work and this way of working the photographer leverages a loneliness
that is inherent in us all. Simon Norfolks says that for his work, beauty
is a seductive tool, he'll draw the audience in with a beautiful image so he
can incite the curiosity about the subject and that's
clearly a currency of photography and all visual storytelling. Though a swaging
loneliness is something else, I asked Isadora who needed who the most?
Was it her needing her subjects or her subjects needing her and her answer is
really striking is when she says that neither need each other but I want them
and they want me, which is I believe a normal response in a long-term
relationship. There's a great deal more to pick up on and once again you've just
heard one short edit of a series of interviews, the rest of which you can now
access via the extended playlist. There's also an additional deep dive interview
with Everyday Africa photographer Nana Kofi Acquah. In that, he addresses the
courses key questions and thinks about notions of interpretation. You'll hear
him describe why he believes the messenger must tune themselves to become
a reflection of the message. Nana also brings a particularly valuable
perspective coming as it does from his professional backgrounds in both radio
journalism and advertising. Hopefully, we'll see you next week in the webinar
and be sure to submit your four corners image in time for it to be included in
the review, don't forget to dig around in the class notes, investigate the hotspots
and see why particular parts of the conversations are being responded to and
by whom. Reach out and connect with people and where you can support those
who can't get into a roomful of fellow students.
I'm Jonathan Wirth and you can connect with me via twitter at Jonathan
underscore Worth.